Russia has hit
Ukraine with a
new wave of attacks,
including numerous drone attacks
launched from the north overnight
and within the past few minutes.
The Ukrainian
prosecutor's office issued a statement
saying that the
southern cities of Aparicio
was hit
by half a dozen missiles
This is video of the moment.
One of those missiles
struck a residential building there.
City officials
say the strike killed one person
and wounded at least 25 others,
including children.
Terrifying moments as residents
tried to grasp exactly what was happening
We'll CNN's
Ivan Watson filed this report
a little earlier
from Kharkiv in northeast Ukraine.
Ukrainian authorities say at least
two Russian
missiles slammed into apartment buildings
in the southern Ukrainian city
of Zappa, Russia.
This attack
taking place on a on a bright, sunlit day
in late winter,
which is kind of deceptively beautiful
when you consider
the deadly hazards of the conflict
that are taking place now.
Now, the search and rescue teams
were on the scene.
These were 29 story apartment buildings.
The acting
mayor of the city says at least
one person has been killed.
Dozens of people hospitalized.
Fire department on the scene
trying to put out the fires.
At least two children
injured in this attack
that has been condemned
by the Ukrainian authorities
as a war crime, as they put it, committed
by vile Russian terrorists.
This attack taking place
the day after the Russian
and Chinese leaders,
Vladimir Putin and Xi Jinping
were embracing each other in Moscow
after two days of meetings
where they declared
to the world
that they want to create a more just more
democratic multipolar
international order.
Within hours of those declarations and
the deep declarations of friendship
between these two leaders,
the Ukrainian authorities say
the Russian military fired
multiple deadly missiles and drones
at different Ukrainian cities and towns.
Missiles fired by Russian warplanes
at the southern port city of Odessa,
where air defenses succeeded in
knocking down
at least two of those missiles.
But more got through,
causing damage to a three storey
building, wounding people.
And then the Ukrainian
Air Force, say,
from the north of Ukraine.
At least
21 of these Iranian made Shaheed
drones were fired at Ukraine
that some 16
were knocked down by air defenses.
But at least four people were killed
in a city outside of Kiev.
In the town of Tomah in that region.
Several of those drones
were knocked down.
The Russians
say that
there were some kind of drone attacks
on the Russian occupied city
of Sevastopol in the Crimean Peninsula.
All of this air war, which kills
and maims civilians, innocent civilians,
is taking place
as the two militaries
continue bludgeoning each other,
killing each other in trench
and artillery warfare
on the very long front lines.
Ivan Watson, CNN, Kharkiv.
Well, Ukraine's president posted
about these separate attacks today,
saying that Russia is shelling the city
with bestial savagery.
Zelensky also making a surprise visit
to the Donetsk region
where he met troops on the front lines
not far from
the location of the longest
and deadliest battle
of this nearly 13 month long war.
He talked to them outside it
inside a warehouse and handed out awards
Well, President Zelensky
also visited wounded soldiers
at a hospital,
giving them awards
and honoring them for their service.
The International Monetary
Fund has announced
it has reached an agreement
to supply Ukraine
with a financial loan
package of $15.6 billion.
The IMF says the package aims to support
Ukraine's recovery as Russia's invasion,
quote, continues
to have a devastating impact
on the economy.